[Music]
in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we're taking you
to the first place birthplace of jazz
New Orleans the pandemic is hitting the
city hard all major concerts are
canceled and the streets are no longer
buzzing with the sound of funk and soul
Matea VI al shows us how some artists
found a way to keep that New Orleans
spirit alive music runs in the blood of
New Orleans natives Megan and Brandon
Bruni Asst it moves them to perform even
at the stage is just their front porch
New Orleans I mean it just never stops
here the music is always there the music
is always gonna be here there's always
going to be music in the hearts of
people and even the people who aren't
musicians they feel music and they want
music that's why they come here
no matter how long like the quarantine
laughs it's not gonna kill the music
scene you know that people will find a
way to express themselves their way now
includes using social media to
livestream shows twice a week it's a two
pronged effort to help keep the music
scene alive while providing a small
stream of income through a virtual tip
jar a new reality that's a far cry from
what they're used to this is the month
that all musicians in New Orleans make
all their money to make it through the
summer which the summer nobody comes to
New Orleans during hurricane season
especially when it's a hundred and ten
in the shade and so that's four or five
months of no business you know it is it
is a gig based kind of system freezing
economy definitely the sound of big
Sam's funky nation a melting pot of funk
hip-hop jazz brass and grooves
has been a vibrant part of the New
Orleans music scene for almost two
decades now forced into online gigs
streaming from the driveway of Sam
Williams house it's great because the
people are very separate they love it
it's just weird for us cuz we don't have
the interaction but you know we got to
keep him users going and keep everybody
reads lifted in the city just dies we
got to keep it going
optimism aside he knows what's at stake
how long can you sustain like this long
how long at all maybe maybe another
month or two
you know so we just gotta hang in there
I hope that Williams resilience is
emblematic of a city that's hit rock
bottom before we've been through a lot
of things Hurricane Katrina you can't
keep us down a sentiment echoed by jazz
clarinetist him Lachlan every day he
performs for 30 minutes on his balcony
in the French Quarter we're making
something very basic into something
really good do you feel like this is
what people need right now yeah somebody
once said listening to a recording is
like looking at a picture of food but
when you hear live music real musicians
in front of you it has a totally
different energy a distinct energy no
matter where you're listening from for
CBS this morning midday RVL New Orleans
so true there's nothing like my live
music and it's gonna be a tough for
quite a while because the concert
Booker's I know are saying it could be a
year before they book big concerts again
oh I don't want to hear that Anthony but
I do want to go to big Sam's funky
nation they look like a fun group yes
and I like to what Meghan said music is
always there even if you're not a
musician music is certainly always in
your heart Tony I know you feel that too
yeah no for sure but particularly the
live variety I mean we were at this
moment I think with music where so many
of us were experiencing it in our cars
or through headphones privately recorded
and now with this shelter at home order
so all over the country people are
performing on
porches in driveways from balconies out
of windows and the kind of communal
nature of music is front and center
again and and I'm all for it so it's one
bright spot yes that's why we got a big
funky nation that's why when it go all
right that's why I want to go to big
Sam's funky nation I'm with you I'm with
you well going